Montréal, et une campagne de
publicité rappelle que c'est
illégal, la prostitution.
- Derrière les voitures
de course, la fête au
centre-ville et les touristes
qui affluent, le Grand Prix
cache une autre réalité.
TRICIA MURRAY, survivante
de l'exploitation sexuelle
- Il y a beaucoup plus de filles
qui affichent sur les sites
à Montréal à l'approche
du Grand Prix, il y a comme
une frénésie autour de ça.
- Tricia Murray est restée
pendant un an dans l'univers
de la prositution. Elle a
connu le week-end du Grand Prix
à Montréal et les clients
aux demandes spéciales.
- Si j'étais mineure ou
si je connaissais une mineure,
ou si j'avais l'air d'une jeune
femme, s'ils pouvaient simuler
l'agression sexuelion sexuelion,
c'était toutes sortes de
demandes comme ça.
- La semaine dernière,
elle a même reçu la proposition
me sur Instagram.
- M'offrant de devenir
sa "sugar baby" pour environ
7000 $ par semaine.
- À l'approche du Grand Prix,
on veut éviter que des femmes
et des filles soient recrutées
par des proxénètes qui cherchent
à répondre à la demande pour
des services sexuels.
Les organismes qui luttent
contre l'exploitation sexuelle
lancent une campagne de
publicité qui sera visible
dans les abribus et
sur les réseaux sociaux
pour rappeler que payer pour
du sexe est illégal au Canada.
JENNIE-LAURE SULLY, Concert.,
luttes contre exploit. sexuelle
- Payer pour un acte sexuel,
c'est l'imposer. Et que
les clients sont à la base
d'un système qui exploite
les femmes et les filles.
- Le Service de police de
la Ville de Montréal a visité
80 hôtels de la métropole,
surtout au centre-ville,
pour demander au personnel
de rester vigilant.
MARCO BRETON, commandant,
Exploitation sexuelle, SPVM
- De nous informer si, à leurs
yeux, il y a des situations
qui sembales ou qui
impliqueraient des juvéniles.
On s'occupe surtout,
en priorité, des juvéniles.
- Mais il n'y aura pas plus
d'opérations qu'à l'habitude
pour arrêter ceux qui achètent
des services sexue
- Si on devait mener
des opérations dans chaque hôtel
pour voir s'il y a des clients,e
c'est presque impossible.
- Selon plusieurs intervenants
du milieu, la police doit
accentuer la répression pour
que les clients cessent d'avoir
un sentiment d'impunité.
MARTINE B. CÔTÉ, chercheuse,
autrice du livre "Faire corps"
- J'ai l'impression qu'une
ou deux opérations clients
très rapprochées dans le temps,s
pourraient donner un signal
fort et rappeler l'existence de
cette infraction criminelle-là.
- Comme il y a pas de
répression, arrestation,
mais ces hommes-là se disent
que c'est permis, que c'est pas.
- Mais pour les victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle,
les séquelles peuvent être
profondes et rester longtemps.
Ici Olivier Bacha
Radio-Canada, M=